I'm recording right now I'm recording on
on the show right now
okay get over here
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of the
careful boys we have with us Mr Chris
Sosa over there
good jacket bro what the hell this is
yeah uh this
wait what does it say oh my God what
does it say now what does it says
default setting when you buy it it
already comes like that yeah
[ __ ] just
that the lower cases aren't lower cases
they're just small caps and then there's
really just a bigger letter
shut the [ __ ] up let me let me see
Johnny let me see that dude it's top
secret Anthony wasn't supposed to be
sure today hey we luckily we have
Anthony back with us again uh what
happened to you dude
I totally legally tested negative for
covid this morning which is why I'm here
thank you
oh [ __ ] dude I told I told your ass too
I was like
who the [ __ ] cares about this test do
you have symptoms are you being a Sneezy
little [ __ ] if you're being a Sneezy
little [ __ ] stay home
minus the [ __ ] I was sneezing I don't
even give a [ __ ] that's an allergies
though you could taste the cuff I could
taste everything I I it was very this is
my second time having covet I've gotten
the booster vaccine
that no no not like six times without
you no you got like six times I think
you caught like four or six times people
came here and said they got it from you
they got four times before the vaccine
and another seven times after the
vaccine yeah
everybody here I think Bart how many
times two right way you had it like a
million times now two million well I
technically had it once because I only
tested like that one time that I got it
but I did get sick maybe like another
five more that's just a cold that could
be a cold but but technically it's not
on paper particularly it's not covered
because you didn't test positive for
Kobe it's a good job so yeah was it
covered symptoms
I never had covet symptoms even when I
had covet I could taste everything the
whole time sounds like you're bragging
this isn't the only thing well then
everything else is flu-like symptoms
they're trying to [ __ ] appropriate
the flu whoa whoa whoa
been trying to [ __ ] appropriate the
flu since day one that's [ __ ] up these
symptoms are unique to the fluid problem
yeah stop sailor oh this is a very like
Asian adjacent or whatever
flu adjacent symptoms
what if they call it the coven flu
you know in retrospect we could all look
back at it and laugh you know it was fun
even a little bit I think it's too fresh
because no one's talking about covet
still no I I actually had the opposite
reaction because when they first said
kung fu I was like
and everyone was like all pissed right
and I'm like oh [ __ ] I'm A Smith about
it huh now everyone's laughing about him
I [ __ ] you you know if you guys laughed
when we're supposed to laugh that's true
yeah you just gotta laugh when a joke is
fresh you don't [ __ ] laugh when it's
all old laugh two years later oh yeah
fresh is 9 11 but it's the day after oh
yeah what was your best 9 11 bit oh dude
I was just talking about how Flight 93
was like 93 million times cooler a movie
yeah [ __ ] than I thought uh Armageddon
was it was way better than be fair
Flight 93 was actually a really powerful
movie that [ __ ] was lit it was a good
movie we're getting it's a good movie
and Nicholas Cage was [ __ ] amazing I
felt like I was there you know I like it
more than Independence Day for sure yeah
not like our independence day I like
Independence the second one sucks dick
have we seen I don't even know there was
a second one the second one it was so
bad I don't even know what happened did
Will Smith punch another alien in the
face he wasn't even in it no he knew he
knew gold blooms and that was it Chris
jacket
I'm recording right now I'm recording on
on the show right now
okay get over here
get over here
have you not been around Asian parents
she thinks you're in danger there's a
stuff called respect dogs when your
parents call you is it all you always
treated like an emergency I the only
thing is uh I think like five years ago
I started being like uh what if they're
calling because like somebody else got
injured or something because damn you
guys are good Sons yeah it took me a
month and a half to call my mom back and
then you got to call her back I caught
her when she called me she's still in
Japan no she's gonna meet me in Hawaii
and it's gonna be [ __ ] awesome
because my nephews are there my
brother's gonna be there I haven't seen
them in like 10 years yeah it's gonna be
cool
that she's gonna be there for like a
whole month yeah and and my stepdad's uh
I don't know if it's kids or some
relatives gonna be there too so I get to
meet them so it's gonna be pretty fun
you're not really connected with your
fam I just go connected enough Chris
Chris ask him about his dad
pretty good it's really good yeah it's
like super light it's really light yeah
let's bring it down bro
say I'm your dad now give me physical
affection what do you do role play role
play [ __ ] 300 kick his stomach
so since five years ago you started
picking up your mom's phone call just
kidding and [ __ ] anything happens yeah I
get scared now you know they're just
like older uh now that like I don't live
at home my sister don't live at home my
sister also has like three kids now so
it's like her response time for anything
like that is like I can't expect you
don't wait for the double call because
what I do with my mom is this I go I see
her call the minute it rings I just hang
up like that yeah and then I go like
this ah [ __ ] she ringed again so it's so
it's a double double call I pick it up
and then it's [ __ ] [ __ ] somebody
I should be triple calling that time
remember how you also talk about like on
here you also talk about how your mom's
like a boss what do you mean what do you
mean you're the one who talks about it
unbreakable head no no like she's she's
[ __ ] my boss is that what you took
from that is that a boss means to you
that's a trait of bosses because we're
talking about old Asian fragile people
right so I'm like then if Anthony thinks
his mom is gonna be like whack dead that
if my mom I'm a boss she's more like
whack stay alive yeah
stay alive I don't know I just I just
didn't process it like that yeah I'm
just surprised it just makes a lot of
sense it was only part that process it
that way huh no way oh it's texting with
his mom that's really [ __ ] funny if
you've ever seen his he'll show you like
yeah yeah for sure it's just a shitload
of Chinese characters and then him going
okay yeah it's so like too long didn't
read cool thanks or the Emoji like this
me [ __ ] boys I just mean like when
you're talking about how your dad's
gonna try and move back in with your mom
your mom's like all right here's the
list rules has like an understanding of
the way things are yeah that [ __ ] don't
fly with my mom I think when Mom calls
you answer you miss it call right back
that's the code dad he'd be all right
I'm gonna call him I'm gonna get back to
him my dad it's a whole like the text
threats with my dad is just pictures of
him this is what 55 looks like son this
is what it is
selfie of associate it ain't easy being
me and so this is my dad Flex is on you
straight up that's all he does he's just
like you want you he wants you to be
like wow dad you look so young for your
ex yeah my dad he'll send like he has a
like a group text with just me and my
and my siblings and my Apostle just it's
only him we don't text like we'll like
like wait he'll just text pictures and
be like you know uh uh there's not a
mirror I don't like
text threads his Instagram account you
say what you guys text thread is his
Instagram account and pretty much yeah
and you guys just like it we just gotta
like it love it looking good Pops I
started sending your own pics back I
should but I think there's no out like
do one right now dude do one right now
right now get a selfie turn around get a
selfie right now send it to your part
this is what big dicks look like picture
yourself yeah where's your penis
there it is
what the [ __ ] do you want me to say from
that [ __ ]
there it is big dicks pop big dicks big
dicks well you know a little below
average you know whatever having a dad
that like faked his death
in the future like if you're ever at his
funeral are you gonna be like going
where you at like you you pulled this
one up again huh sequel huh you don't
have to tell the whole story but what
was the method of death real quick okay
so he uh oh the method of how he did it
a bullet hole to the head he faked a
bullet hole to the head and put himself
in a ditch like in underwear it was on
the news and everything and we did a JK
news video about it before we met Chris
yeah and his dad wrote a book about
after he came back to life yeah your dad
wrote a butler Amazon bro carpet I
walked on my own grave yeah yeah it's
sick dude in that time so hard
he's like what do you think of that I
walked away from grape was it a I can't
remember if it was a plan he was like
well obviously the plan but if he was
like I plan on one day mining the [ __ ]
out of this for for Content oh no no no
no no because the story got so big it
made him get bigger he's like oh this is
this is this is a story this is
compelling and it's like already my dad
already loves himself so the fact that
this went like worldwide the story went
you know big he's calling me giving me
all his credits Like Son HBO Bobby I'm
gonna be on HBO it's gonna be a whole
thing ABC datelines all he's been on all
these networks bro wow yeah for real
he's been he has more credits than I do
I've been chasing my dream for like nine
years he fakes a death
is he um great enough to work anymore he
just makes so much money from the book
stuff no he works bro he works he's a
he's a uh he's been working at FedEx for
like over 30 years like 35 37 years you
wrote that in his face
he went from like truck driving now he
trains uh uh he's a trainer now but he's
like the Sensei there training FedEx
Sensei yeah FedEx essay well I did I did
bring up the fact that he was a
professional boxer and now he's a
professional boxer
so that that sunk in that sunk in a
little bit
today's video is brought to you by
Babble you know for all you uh in cells
out there that are trying to talk to
chicks
one of the easiest way to break the ice
is to speak something that people don't
expect you to speak so for example when
you're a white guy and you're able to go
up to like an Asian girl and go Nihao
and you say all this Chinese [ __ ] the
Asian chick's like what that's crazy oh
they could be like what I'm all red yeah
get out of here or if you're Asian and
you can speak Italian or German you know
sense of humor and being able to connect
with different cultures is a very easy
way to break the ice and you know what's
an easy way to learn Babble that's right
baby with 10 minute lessons it takes the
freaking tedious boring learning out of
the brain and into the brain is a real
easy simple way yeah and Babel got
speech recognition technology so that
you actually get help pronouncing and
enunciating the words the right way and
they got 14 different languages that you
can choose from so that means that's 14
whole different countries you can flirt
in and they got a 20-day money-back
guarantee so if you're trying to learn
another language and if you're not
learning or you're like this doesn't
work my brain doesn't operate this way
you can get your money back within 20
days oh yeah right now you get up to 55
off your subscription when you go to
babel.com off the Record that's
babble.com off the record for up to 55
off your subscription Babble language
for Life bro I saw my dance I saw my
dad's box wreck which is like any boxer
You Ever Wanted like professional box
you want to know about you go to BoxRec
and find other stuff I saw my dad's box
wreck his last fight bro was a TKO he
lost TKO and it says in parentheses Sosa
knocked out of ring oh he got oh [ __ ]
ouchies
I call my pops bro I'm like yo you're a
[ __ ]
but I brought it up to him to put that
information it's not that deep that's
what yo that should be like this was 35
[ __ ]
this is like they said like it said like
uh 1985 and I I I sent that to him and
like he called me right away no man
that's so [ __ ] I'm like that this
was an 85 but he still is like no no no
no no no no I went down I swear honestly
no no I faked The Knockout too yeah I
jumped out the ring and I faked it I
have another book for that and put a
bullet hole in my hand
someone shot me outside The Gunshot of
the people someone sniper yeah that was
a soft spot yeah I got him I got him
that was something but you know he broke
it down to me I said all right he said
my foot my back foot so you know when
you're leaning back on the rose it
slipped out yeah he knew exactly like
every move I was like wow that really
you just fall out of the ring like that
it's a loss like automatic no like I
mean no I don't know it was it was
enough he said that when he got like got
back up he was he was so like Dazed like
uh you know like out of it I'm like well
pause that that's like a knockout but
you know what I'm saying you can fall in
trouble and kind of get up and he's like
I got up too fast I think yeah hey
that's happened that does happen no bro
but I was just sitting there all day and
I stand up too fast oh man that's like a
TKO yeah same thing out of ring out of
ring all right
you told that story about what a little
[ __ ] your dad is in front of a show
with hundreds and hundreds and hundreds
of people watching oh the show the show
also soldiers told his story about you
know his story and you know the fake his
dad he got his book did he watch the JK
news that we did of course yeah he sent
it to me that he didn't know but I
already know yeah he was like check out
you know when it happened everything
every time his story's out he's on it
more than anybody I pull up box wreck
real quick it's there man is it better I
guess to his ego if he got knocked out
in the ring the versus out of the ring
because it to me if you got knocked out
you got knocked out but to him it's like
oh no I wasn't out of the ring I got
knocked out in the ring I don't know man
I just know I just know he he uh you
know he told me he told me what's up he
told me what it is and that's the that's
still my pop disclaimer he's still a
superhero to me all right that's my guy
we're talking [ __ ] that's it but I had
to use your imagination I had to be like
yo Pops they didn't have to put the
parentheses there but it's there what
are your favorite superheroes guys who
get [ __ ] knocked out
out of the ring what's your dad's first
name uh Ramon r-a-m-o-n trying to think
of a superhero gets like laid out that
sounds like a professional wrestler yeah
like Razor Ramon yeah what's what's his
uh boxing record oh that's that looks
just like you
let me see it he's like wait that's not
my dad oh wow dude that's uncanny
because he looks good he looks different
now that's my pops man I love him man
what's what was his record I don't know
it says 4-2-0 yeah hey one knockout one
knockout on the other eye so he had four
is that is it bike the last two fights
for four wins two losses and what's oh
no drops no draws oh and then one is an
extra one outside the ring
1987.
talked out of the ring in third
round it actually happens though people
get knocked out of the ring as soon as
they stop the fight because the guys
will get hurt when they fall off the
road he told me straight up though he
said he said that he wasn't uh he wasn't
prepared he wasn't even like uh he was
kind of like that fight he did say
honestly I wouldn't even like prepared
for like you know did they say uh
knocked out of the ring with foldable
table and chair yes TLC match should we
hire somebody on Fiverr to like delete
the parentheses off his record yeah he's
like they don't even that's not even how
it went it's not even that don't even
allow who did we got to figure out who
wrote that in the 80s yeah who was the
[ __ ] behind that dude yeah yeah and
then we gotta ask them why because the
internet would like like I mean they had
when was the internet come out
for the consumers I feel like in the 90s
basically so that was on paper first so
whenever it came whenever it gets from
the end of they're like well make sure
we put that in
bro yeah
there was a boxer that got knocked out
recently and he fell out the ring can
you look it up and see if they put it in
there McMahon m-i-c-k Conlin
c-o-n-o-n-l-a-n and that's really
contact the guy who knocked your dad out
and just gets the full story
that's a book we'll see how that guy
looks at 55. oh yeah let's say if they
do a rematch yeah he looks incredible
oh no oh that would kill my dad he works
at UPS too yeah
do FedEx guys go man UPS that'd be so
sick
that's their dream you have to sign up
for an account online what what the [ __ ]
is this
you get you get one and when you sit on
his dad
we probably have like 60 accounts now
just as who signs up for this [ __ ]
web series dude that's ridiculous some
of my favorite Fighters now we hate it
yeah it happens yeah man you're like
boom hits the ground starts rolling
under the ropes that never happened to
you no so one of my favorite Fighters
and it's a really epic fight it's uh
between Quinton Jackson and vandelay
Silva this is a backing pride in Japan
Silva gets him in like a tie clinch he
knees him in the face and then on his
way back he lets go and Quentin Jackson
literally just flies out the like yeah
and he was just out and he's like his
body's like bouncing on the ropes and
[ __ ] like that so it happens to like
Professor defense he makes Sports bets
on fights is that in the thing where
you're like gets knocked out gets
knocked out of the ring how much people
that must be like picking zero on a
[ __ ] roulette table there's probably
a parlay thing I bet you would put this
in there
dropped yo because he knows how much you
know we love boxing they know how much I
love you know how how he gets down I was
just like damn cause you know it was a
whole thing of why I'm not a
professional boxer he was like you know
protecting me and like but you know you
do so much why would you even want to be
a boxer you're so talented all this
stuff and I saw that I was like damn I
wonder if like his fears were put onto
me you know what I'm saying like not
wanted to you know you just drop your
dreams and start boxing oh man I mean I
always I think about it [ __ ] that don't
do it yeah see since the whole thing but
I think being an influencer and then
boxer has proven that that's there's
more money that's the new model well
Jake just made like 40 mil or something
would you be down to jump more into that
like there's one happening this weekend
that Austin McBroom dude he's fighting
like there's literally like a uh as many
regular boxing matches there's as many
influencer boxes it might be open to it
bro 100 I wanna like I thought about
like uh uh like Justin Bieber because it
has to be big I want to find somebody
like Justin Bieber or Chris Brown
Holland you don't want to fight Chris
Brown dude yeah he knows how to beat up
a lot of
Chris Brown's really smart about picking
his opponents would you like to would
you like to read out Nick's official
fight record dude oh can I read it oh
[ __ ]
they didn't even get my first win dude
that's [ __ ] it's a zero and one and
zero ties I'm actually a 500 fighter so
watch your [ __ ] mouths okay hey dude
way to rep the [ __ ] Flag yeah
what's your real
recording in the first minute I told you
I'm a failed fighter here's my favorite
part career disclosed earnings zero
dollars
how come it only has one of your fights
don't you have like four or five of them
yeah cause you know this is all nonsense
too bro because you don't have to sign
up for an account
me around like oh [ __ ] damn dude I'm not
even five eight that's [ __ ] I'm five
seven dude it says it right here seven
at least that's a win for me
it sees his ears are fake shut up Chris
I told you that confidence for nothing
take those babies off those ears
pop them off trade ears of me dog that's
really sorry I picked I picked a very
obscure website that's not the first
result that website you should go by
that nickname it says not available
not available
you can't reach them my arms are not
long enough to be recorded zero dollars
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and they never even been in your shoes
to go to battle to begin with but you
just gave them the ammo to roast you for
[ __ ] life Hey where's Bart's thing
that he just showed up to and the guy
Bart has a has a better track record
than Nick and botsnet Bart's number five
guy named Nick Ivan Velasquez yeah I
beat a guy like that like that Velasquez
dude he wasn't even a real guy honestly
Bart's a Jujitsu Champion dude that one
fight what I personally think it was an
early stoppage I think the ref stopped
you a little too soon yeah at the one
minute 23 Second Mark in the first round
and that guy started throwing punches at
me and I was like this guy trying to
knock me out I was like what the [ __ ] I
remember thinking that yeah dude says
you're five eight in this website too I
guess I'm 5'8
174 centimeters but then this if you're
wondering this same website also says
you haven't won or lost any well this
one that says that you got a loss to
Eric in the third round at two minutes
fight that guy again in parenthesis a
unanimous decision from the judges yeah
I should honestly low-key think I should
have won that fight too but hey that's
what it is I wish you were so insecure
about it that you actually tracked that
guy down and you had a camera crew film
you just kick his ass in public
fight on the street exactly the new most
non-threatening photo of you as your
profile
with a Heineken hand on the hip that's
my signature this is you have one fight
one win and one loss dude if you if
you're gonna get matched up to fight
against a guy like that
dude I'm gonna kick this guy's [ __ ]
ass kick his hiney I'm licking my
[ __ ] I think my career earnings are
going up
[Music]
[Music]
foreign